[Music]
foree
speee
[Music]
fore
spee
[Music]
for
[Applause]
speee
[Music]
Fore there are time s when a piece of
media comes along that seems to become
something bigger than just another show
something that didn't just impact a
small group of people but blew past into
the heights of popular culture to edch
its way into the collective memories of
everyone who was around in that time
period it becomes generational when you
look back you not only remember
everything that show did but also the
era of your life that show represented
for many of us Attack on Titan was that
show that was there through the Journey
we took to adult life not that show we
started watching when we were some dumb
kid that we've grown up from now but the
show that we found when we were
transitioning into a new phase of Life
discovering the harsh realities and
responsibilities that came with it that
we may or may not have been prepared for
and now 10 years later that Journey has
come to an end Attack on Titan is
finally
[Music]
over it's been one hell of a journey one
that I've been on right from episode one
so now after having just seen the final
moments of the final episode of the
final parts of the final season sorry
had to one more for the road I have a
mess of thoughts and feelings that I'm
going to try and lay out coherently as
best I can what did I think of the
ending was I satisfied what kind of
Legacy did Attack on Titan leave all of
that coming up after I talk about
today's sponsor Ark Knights oh God I'm
going to fall back into Ark knites again
aren't I Ark knits is a strategic RPG
with an immersive story set within the
fictional Universe of Terror you have
the role of the doctor in this world
where the oropy disease poses the utmost
Menace and it's up to you to command
several operators to fight against the
antagonist on their journey to discover
a remedy for the ailment yes if you
didn't know me and the boys were
addicted to aranit for a while but now
arice is bringing the low and Trail
story running from November 7th to
December 5th in this brand new Side
Story event as the arzer project is
nearing its conclusion director ciren
Wright vanished along with the equipment
and Technical staff the roads Island
team while working to thwar the military
attacks on the Ryan lab is
simultaneously searching for the
whereabouts of the director joining us
on the journey are four new operators we
have muis and ecologist holak a COR
castle with the ability to make targets
levitate silence the paradigmatic A
Healer whose Talent applies Sanctuary
within an attack range and melanite who
serves as a head shooter which is
exactly as it sounds with her
revolutionary Armament being able to
dish out massive damage during the event
doctors have the opportunity to earn
rewards by participating in the relevant
tasks and through the event store just
to note that the special case contact CU
Cod store will only be open for un
limited time and not forgetting there
are seven new skins with 13 returning
skins woo can't wait for the bloodline
skins myself so what are you waiting for
Ark Knight is available on IOS and
Android right now and you can download
it today by clicking that link in the
description it's been a while since I
talked about Attack on Titans so much so
people were starting to believe that i'
just fallen out of Interest with it but
the truth is I just didn't have that
much new to add the final season
continued being hype continued
delivering on its complex political
drama did anything big happen since the
last time I talked about it oh yeah the
end of the world the big thing was of
course eron initiating the rumbling
which was a plot development I had no
idea was coming nuh-uh no way any of us
could have predicted this was actually
going to happen this was our red wedding
our Thanos snap a world shaking
fictional event that I believe will
remain as a pop culture reference for
years to come and it's an event like
this that exemplified what Attack on
Titan does best when you hear about a
disaster it's sometimes hard to
rationalize in your mind one person
dying is a tragedy a million people
dying is a statistic and the one amazing
thing about the rumbling is it truly
makes you feel the gravity of what that
statistic actually means this isn't just
a percentage or a number on on a page
these are people individual people
fighting tooth and nail in a situation
that is so far beyond saving the true
weight of Erin's decision is laid bare
in front of you here is Humanity at
their darkest Point yet somehow through
the cruelty you see glimpses of hope
that shine through just the roest
moments of human nature and emotions
this is just beautiful one of my
favorite episodes is the one where the
characters we've grown to know on every
side are just sitting in the circle
discussing their next plans no action no
big developments just a group of people
talking trying to rational Iz together
an almost hopeless situation words are
exchanged emotions run High you get to
see the raw side of these characters
being put in a position they' never
thought they'd be in and you're just
sitting there going oo that's some spicy
tea it takes a special show to be able
to just put some people in a room let
that scene play out and have that be as
gripping as seeing two Goliath beings
locking fists this to Simply put is just
compelling television the Legacy the
show had built was one that was not
afraid to take risks not afraid to break
the mold evolve change up the entire
reason you began watching in the first
place leading to some of the most
gripping moments you can find in
entertainment how do you even begin to
go about concluding all these characters
all these plot threads 10 years worth of
buildup would it rise up to meet the
Colossal weight of expectations it had
or would it lose it all slip and
fall why I put that in the
script so someone used my email and
emailed Studio wit hello I am anime
reviewer gig
I will make a request of you many people
want Aaron and masassa to have a
relationship aarin X masassa I think if
this happens many people will enjoy the
anime
more the prophecy is true so this is it
the ending if I had to pick a single
word to describe my emotions after the
ending it would be satisfied coming into
this mangar readers had me believing
that Game of Thrones season 8 was about
to get a new sibling but instead what I
saw was an imperfect sometimes sound a
little messy but ultimately A fitting
conclusion to a series that had already
achieved so much over the years for a
series that took so many risks I'm sure
there were some people that were
disappointed that everything ended in a
pretty safe manner nothing too overly
sad nothing too overly happy nothing
really fell out my realm of expectations
and to me that was completely fine
there's already a million different
opinions on every single little detail
every scene every line who should have
died who should have lived but pretty
much my only issues boiled down to
things revolving around the Titan law
and this single scene oh oh no
please I can't do this again no one of
the big question marks I had was where
was Aaron ultimately going with all this
what were the consequences going to be
for initiating the rumbling what was
Aaron able to achieve by massacring
millions if not billions of people I
don't know seems legit it's revealed
that Aaron didn't really know what he
was doing he was just an idiot who fell
into power and got lost along the way ah
yes another classic example of men who'd
rather commit genocide risk his friends
dying ensure the death of his own mother
then seek a therapist for real though I
actually really liked this idea that
Aaron was at heart the same angry
emotional kid we saw at the beginning
from the get-go we see Aaron as a person
who tried to solve all his problems
through impulse and rage and as he got
older learns more about the world learns
that human conflict is way more complex
and nuanced than he ever imagined it to
be while obtaining the power to make a
real change the only solution he could
come up with was the only solution he
ever knew kill kill Titans kill humans
kill everyone that got in the way of his
freedom when in the end it was that very
Freedom that had enslaved him the
biggest trick Erin ped on his friends on
the world on us was convincing us that
he was him he tried to be Louch and
realized too late you're not that guy
pal trust me I freaking love this idea
and it felt like such a fitting
conclusion for the character where this
got a bit messy is when you throw this
in with all the Titan timey wiy
see he wanted his friends to become the
heroes by slaying him but also he was
going to wipe out 100% of humanity
anyway of given him the chance so he's a
psychotic idiot oh but wait his mind's a
mess cuz he sees the past present and
future simultaneously this was a
predetermined timeline where he actually
initiated the death of his mom Titan
power mechanics the paths coordinates
these shines through when they are used
to put characters in difficult
situations with tough choices to make
the stakes are high and the consequences
are always clear but I came out of this
conversation not exactly knowing what
choices Aaron had to make was this the
only timeline he was tragically forced
to enact was the rumbling a decision he
made based on different Futures he saw
was he trying to set up a code guos
ending for his friends was this all a
facade and he had no idea what he was
doing was it all of the above well could
have something clear and concise felt a
bit jumbled up and I thought by just
having a few more scenes to really give
a glimpse into what was really going on
in his head it could have saved a lot of
confusion oh he just got called cringe
by Armen aren it's over and this is
pretty much my sentiment for every other
big reveal in the final conversation
turns out Aaron and mcasa had feelings
for each other the entire time instead
of having some sibling type relationship
oh and so did yir who actually loved
King Fritz the person that burned down
her Homeland murdered her parents and
tore out her tongue that was the thing
that bound her for 2,000 years she was
just looking for someone to break her
out of her shackles of love and that
real special chosen person was actually
Mikasa
why the one thing that consistently blew
my mind watching Attack on Titan is that
no matter how crazy the plot got it
always felt so natural every major
development was meticulously crafted
every twist carefully planned out and
for shadowed compared to that a lot of
this felt like we were thrown this out
of left field Aon and masassa having
feelings for each other yamia having
some Twisted love for her King masassa
being her chosen one all of these are
interesting ideas that I kind of see
what the intention is and I guess it
kind of makes sense but for the very
first time I didn't feel that same
airtight execution as everything that
came before it especially since it took
the true ship that was foreshadowed this
entire
[Music]
time
all right rant over I realized that I've
just spent the last few minutes
nitpicking details but I hope you
understand that this is only compared to
the insanely high standards the series
had set itself previously with a show
that juggled so many moving Parts
characters geopolitics time travel Titan
law mechanics if my only complaints is a
messy execution on a few aspects in the
final scene it in no way hampers the
show's accomplishments and all I really
wanted anyway was for it to nail its
final message which it did i' said
before that with everything the series
had done all it needed to do was land on
two feet and while I don't think we got
that perfect 10 out of 10 Landing to me
this more felt like oh okay impressive
impressive oh no oh oh was it going to
fumble oh oh
oh all right we take those we got the
short-term happiness that Aaron yearned
for the people he loved got to live out
the long peaceful lives they deserved
everyone we care about got the send offs
they so rightfully earned but it was
only a matter of time before the peace
they fought so hard for ended War breaks
out and the cycle begins a new it showed
us no matter how hard one person tries
no matter what change you enact conflict
is inevitable and humanity is doomed to
repeat itself who won who lost everyone
won and everyone lost and to me that
felt like a cruel but poetic ending to
the unforgivingly harsh World Attack on
Titan presented us with but you know
what even though on paper this is
technically a really Grim ending it
didn't make me feel hopeless like the
characters we know the harsh reality of
the world this was a series that was
unforgiving to every person in it that
was willing to put its characters
through unimaginable suffering and pain
placed them in a living hell yet despite
this they struggled on anyway why
because no matter how Bleak no matter
how dark there is still a willingness to
hope for a better tomorrow while
acknowledging the harsh truths of today
that's what Attack on Titan meant to me
it might not be the greatest ending of
all time but it is to me the fitting
ending to one of the greatest stories
we've seen in anime this was a tale that
has given me every emotion Under the Sun
a story that has shocked me touched me
inspired me in a way few pieces of art
ever could and I don't doubt that it
will be a long time before we see a
series like this come around again this
wasn't just a show that blew up in the
anime Community this was a show that
grew up with the anime Community a show
that blasted past the reach of what we
thought anime was capable of and showed
the world just how great this medium
could be some of us discovered anime
because of this show some of us fell
back in love with anime because of this
show some of us will never forget anime
because of this show years from now when
you're reminiscing about that time every
convention was filled with survey core
uniforms having a knee-jerk reaction to
someone shouting Sago the emotional Rush
of hearing Irwin's last speech the
collective shock of seeing the rumbling
being initiated and some person goes I
don't get it there's only one reply you
can say you just had to be there this is
what it means to be a generation
defining show this wasn't just the end
of another anime this was the end of an
[Music]
era